last question uh give me your if you're
on it who are the other three artists on
the Baton Rouge hip hop Mount
Rushmore if it's Fredo bang and you you
can exclude yourself if you want but I
I'll leave that up to you I I think I
think I put enough word game to be on
there okay so Fredo's on it there's
three three more spots on Mount Rushmore
it's four people me Gates yes uh buy of
course your cousin weby and Webby that's
three uh you said Bon Rich
yeah little F
okay and dude and dude I went visited
dude I
know he's a nice guy and and I also
wanted to commend you guys for the unity
in the community thing was that about a
year
ago I think so yeah was about a year and
some change ago which was a big deal I
was trying not to I was trying to be the
first interview ever where dude wasn't
brought up that you've done but yeah I
don't and he still technically hasn't
been brought up cuz he's just dude yeah
yeah listen cuz I I I really you know I
really hate when people bring him up cuz
I feel like it be unfair cuz I feel like
when y'all not and I'm not saying this
in no type of negative way I'm just I
feel like when they when when people get
even with Gill though like I that's why
I say I'm not saying in a negative way
cuz I [__] with y'all you know I [__]
with you personally when people
interview him they don't be want to [__]
up the chance of of the interview and
stuff so they don't bring me up to him
you feel I be feel like it's kind of
like you know what my Approach with that
interview was um I felt
like I have had zero relationship with
for him right yeah know I said I
understand but I just say it's unfair in
my Cor in my for me because it be making
me look like I'm always talking about
him you feel me which I know it's just I
I know it ain't that well I think you're
and I think both of you guys are like so
mentally mature past whenever you guys
had whatever y'all had that you know
that's why that when I saw you guys did
the community event um with with his
team and your and and your team I just
thought that was a big deal but you know
my approach to that whole situation was
like I don't want to uh do more of what
is expected and that would be bringing
up dirt I understand and then they
probably would have shut that [__] down
soon as ask about me I didn't even I see
to credit to to him it was just him and
I talking right and and and and um you
know uh I just I knew my Approach with
that was
like most people probably talk to him
like he's an alien right but he's just a
dude you know what I'm saying he's got
kids like I got kids like you got kids
like let's just shoot the [__] and I you
know I didn't want to get into too much
of that cuz I don't have a previous
relationship with him it's cool though
cuz I be understand y' got a job and you
know what I'm saying it just be to the
fans it make it look like I'm always
speaking on him cuz when they some about
when the blogs cut something up it be me
talking you know what I'm saying well
look y'all passed it man I'm a open book
so people can get that out of me you
feel me well y'all passed it man 2024
new [__] new money finally new music
finally new music finally January 19th
the new album is out yes I'm sad which I
think is a great as that's a hey man
look so far it's been a good year for
music because this is new 21 Savage send
it to you let you hear I want to hear it
before it drops have you heard the new
21 Savage album that dropped yesterday
fire fire he always got some good
production it's oh my God his Beats man
I look forward to hearing your album
everybody should go him and Drake the
best with grabbing the concept and Ross
Ross got the best beats it's Ross 21
Drake yeah Ross Ross and um Ross's ears
for Beats is crazy me their production
was good yeah but as far as the total
package 21 and Drake always know how to
get a get a subject wrap a theme around
it and deliver like that [__] the
American dream and all that that [__] is
fire well listen your album's coming out
on the 19th everybody go support it if
you pre-order you get the full artwork
right uh Kevin Gates is on it
Rob 49 who else Ross inre so go go
support the album new videos coming
there's a lot going on man so I
appreciate you man Studio we I played it
yeah we'll go over we we'll walk over to
the studio and listen to the new [__]
right now um go support pre-order hey
stop [__] streaming buy the [__]
album on iTunes man I don't why you
streaming too though no but stream it
but also go to iTunes and spend $10 and
put some money in this man's pocket
immediately yeah a million streams is
$3,800 y'all support the [__] artist
buy the album merch too merch coming you
uh no I'm kind of late with that you got
get that [__] see you're [__]
slipping bro get it together he needs
merch he needs all that [__] merch is on
the way it better be on the [__] way
I'm going get little something put I'm
pull the package together there it is
Fredo appreciate you brother